(gentle intense music)
- Welcome to the Think Marketing Show,
the number one podcast for growing
and scaling your business
with online video.
I'm Heather Torres.
- And I'm Sean Cannell,
and we're from Think Media.
And if this is your first
time listening, welcome.
- This show is dedicated
to helping you learn
how to get your content noticed
and the latest moneymaking strategies
working right now online.
So whether you wanna
grow your YouTube channel
or maximize online video
across social media,
this is for you.
This is a big one.
- Yeah.
- Today we're talking about the
top trends in video in 2020.
They change, and people
need to be in the know
of what's happening right
now for their business,
for their nonprofit, for their church.
Because it's important
to get your message out,
and it's important to understand
where the market is going.
And we have the expert here,
so I'm excited to ask you,
what are five trends that
you see happening right now?
Trend number one.
- Yeah, I'm fired up.
Number one is I actually
think that in 2020 and beyond
it is shifted to quality is
more important than quantity.
- That's big. Tell us about that.
- And let me finish and say,
but I actually think it's
both quality and quantity.
But if you had to pick one,
I think quality is now the dominant thing.
Now, that's kind of a very confusing thing
that can intimidate people
because they think, okay, wait,
I gotta get a $4,000 red camera
and I gotta get custom lighting.
It's not that.
It's the content value,
not the production value.
It might be something shot on a phone.
It doesn't even mean
that it's super planned.
But what it means is that quality matters.
And I think that what we saw in the past
was sometimes a pressure to
just go like live every day,
just get like a lot of
content and be there.
But that content had no value
a week later or a month later,
or to just try to put out as
many pieces of content a day.
And, of course, Gary V. is
talking about like published 50,
100 pieces of content a day.
And that's the quantity
piece that does matter.
But what I'm talking about
is I think the trend is
that quality is what rises
to the top on any platform.
That in some cases with
organic reach going down,
you might only get a few chances
to get in front of people.
So here's the question to ask,
what experience are they
having with your brand
when you get that chance.
When they get to meet you
and they give you a shot,
they see your video in their feed,
they see that YouTube video,
you even rank for a search term.
And when you first optimize a
video, it shows up on YouTube
and they might let you rank for awhile
and they're going to see
what people think about it.
And when people watch that
video, what is their experience?
And I think because we now have helped
even over like almost 4,000 people in
our Video Ranking Academy community,
I've noticed that sometimes
people just feel this pressure
and they feel like it's
like a badge of honor.
I upload seven days a week
and I almost feel like
maybe you should upload
only one day a week,
but take all the energy you
are putting into the seven
into one to make it higher quality.
The last analogy when I think of quality
is the difference between writing a book
and writing a tweet.
A lot of people feel the pressure
to post on Instagram
every day, write a tweet,
post on Twitter 10 times a day.
But someone who sits down,
and there's a great book
about this called Deep Work
by Cal Newport, who's known for
not really being on
social media that much,
but when he puts out a blog post,
very rarely or when he puts out a book,
it is a bestseller and it impacts
and it lives on for weeks,
months, and years to come.
Now, I'm not saying every
YouTube video is a book.
I'm saying that's the mindset,
is leaning more on quality
because what we've learned
with YouTube being a search
engine ranking videos
that when we take longer
to make something better
that we can reap the rewards
from that piece of content
for weeks, months, and years to come.
When we rush something, we might get
some quick action that day,
but we have to wake up the next day.
It's like fast fashion versus
something high quality.
It's like investing in
something you wash twice
and it falls apart versus something
you can hand down to your
kids for generations.
Quality over quantity in 2020
- I love how you said
that at the beginning too.
It doesn't necessarily
mean the production value,
so I can still produce
content with my smartphone,
but it's the quality of the content.
It's what you're putting out there.
And it's leveling up, obviously,
you don't wanna just
everything to be raw and real.
It should definitely
have value wrapped in it.
But I love that you said,
it's not necessarily
about leveling up the tech
because that's not necessarily
what's gonna change it.
It really is about the
content and the value
that you're exchanging
- The substance, and you're
a great example of this.
On your homeschool channel,
you think about the substance
and in other cases, when
it comes to homeschool,
how many books have you read on the topic?
- Almost everyone out, maybe 50 bucks.
- So I think a lot of people
when it comes to mastering
their subject matter,
they have read no books about this subject
or they've read one and they have
a surface level understanding.
When you've read 50 versus reading one,
your depth of knowledge
and even your comparison
of the different ideas is
deeper, that's substance.
So if you just shoot
on a webcam with, yes,
I think you do need it,
and that's what we have at Think Media.
So our channel all about
tech, you need some lighting
and maybe a USB microphone,
but this stuff doesn't
have to break the bank.
For like $100, you could
get a webcam, a USB mic
and you're good to go.
But the substance of what you're teaching,
so taking more time on the
content that you're creating
and then speed also matters as well.
And here's maybe the best way to put this.
We are applying these trends.
These are the trends we're living.
I have felt, we have felt
when it comes to Think Media,
video influencers, a
decline in organic reach
by just doing the same things
we've been doing in the past,
same old thumbnails,
kind of same old content,
same old videos over and over.
That's why we're launching
the Think Marketing Show.
We're trying to do new
things, do different things,
starting videos in different ways.
Really actually think about
mastering an organization
of what we're putting together.
We realize we need to level up,
and that's what I'm saying.
In 2020 and beyond, you have
to invest in your skills.
Take your quality to another level.
Don't compare yourself to
anybody on the right or the left,
but just say, how do I take
my quality to a higher level?
Substance as well as
the overall presentation
of the value I'm
delivering to the end user.
- So key, so key.
So number two, what's the second trend
that you're seeing
happening going into 2020
that business owners,
and content creators,
and nonprofit owners, and churches need
to be taking a notice too?
- Yeah, I think the other big
trend is short form video,
and this shouldn't come
as news to anybody,
but we've seen Instagram stories,
Tik Tok is blowing up,
and that's something
that could be interesting to people.
But stories are also on Facebook.
Stories are also on YouTube.
And if you already have some
YouTube influence, shoot,
I mean that--
You were just telling me,
like I gotta double down
because we have YouTube influence,
but it's kind of a
feature that you're like,
you forget that it's there.
And I think there's a couple
of things with stories.
Not only is it the fact that
there's the chance to reach people
and go deeper with your current community,
but it's actually learning
a new way of communication,
like learning to communicate on stories.
I remember even when
Snapchat was first big
for a little bit wider of an audience,
it's still going for
a certain younger age,
but now it's mainly Instagram
stories and Facebook stories,
that at first it was almost like
it took another part of my brain
and it sort of stressed me out,
and I only was thinking
in long form YouTube,
and I didn't think I had
the bandwidth to do it.
And I dunno, let us know in the comments
if you've ever felt that way.
Like, I gotta learn something new
because that is how it feels at first.
But just like learning to ride a bike
or just like learning a new skill set.
Like, at one point, you had to learn
how to use Microsoft Word
or turn the computer on
or how to use Excel,
but then it just became a core competency
that you do without thinking.
It almost like a habit.
That short form communication
is something that we need to learn.
Quick hits of information,
communicating in short sound bites
and being able to stitch
together different pieces
of communication we found.
I mean, our business has
scaled and grown from
how I use Instagram stories,
how Think Media as a team
repurposes some of those things
turns them into video ads
or turns them into posts
on other platforms.
We're using stories in
a lot of creative ways.
So I think short form video,
in general, is a major trend
that people need to be paying attention to
and leaning in on.
I mean, how do you feel about it?
- Yeah, I think what I love
about short form is that
it can be real and raw and in the moment.
I know we've talked about
it on Think Media before,
but your vlog, people
say, "Sean, we wanna see
a vlog from you."
And you say, "I got that.
It's over on Instagram.
You can go follow you on Instagram.
And you see the Rise & Grind show.
That is your daily vlog
of how you're showing
the behind the scenes of what's happening.
And followers love that.
They really love being able
to be a part of your world
and they're getting to know you.
They're getting to know your wife,
they're getting to know your dogs,
they're getting to know
your favorite green juice,
they're starting to find
these similarities with you.
What I love about it is, for me,
I was scared to get on camera.
It was something that
wasn't natural to me.
And so, I used it because
it goes away on Snapchat
or before, I'm sorry,
on Instagram stories.
You can use it and it goes away.
So if you mess up, that's fine.
It's just a short form piece of content.
But it is such a great way
of being able to tell a story
and be able to communicate.
And I think if business
owners, or churches,
or nonprofits grasp this concept
and can communicate in small pieces,
they can earn trust in
a very small way first
then leading them into longer form.
So when you're shouting out a
video that's over on YouTube,
you're giving value in 15 seconds,
but leading them to maybe a
20-minute or 30-minute video,
they've gained that trust with you.
And so, they will go and
make that connection.
So it's a really great tool to be using
for yourself as a communicator,
but also to be able to build
trust with your audience.
In celebration of the launch
of this brand new podcast,
we're giving away two tickets
to our annual conference,
Grow With Video Live, a $1,500 value.
- All you have to do to enter is
make sure you subscribe, leave
us a review on Apple podcast
and then take a screenshot of your review
and go to thinkmarketingshow.com
for the rest of the details.
Trend number three is
I would say Instagram overall,
still a mega platform.
We love YouTube, of course.
Things are happening on Tik Tok.
We just mentioned that, that's
probably not for all ages,
but actually something that
we are paying attention to
and we're seeing who knows where it'll go.
Definitely have your sites on Tik Tok.
So, that's mentioned, but
Instagram is right there
as like kind of the dominant
social platform, right?
- Mm-hmm.
- All ages are there.
It's aging up.
But what we'd wanna hit here is IGTV.
I think that at first
Instagram TV came out
and it was like it kind of,
wow, this is gonna be big
and it kind of died.
And then what happened was they allowed it
to integrate better with Instagram itself,
especially with the preview.
And anyone on Instagram knows that now
you're in the feed and something starts,
it's just a normal Instagram post,
but if it's longer than 60 seconds,
there's that little button
to say finish watching
and it takes you over to IGTV
where now you can upload up to 10 minutes.
And if you upload from
a desktop or if you have
a verified account or enough followers,
you can even upload to
an hour on Instagram TV.
It was also limited to only vertical.
They opened it up to now
you can do horizontal,
and so, it'll be horizontal in the feed.
If you go over to Instagram
TV, hit widescreen,
flip the phone.
And so, even execution there
has become a lot simpler.
And we've noticed that
when our views on IGTV were
like almost nothing, like
compared to the following
on Instagram that we
have over on the IGTV,
it would be just 10% or less.
Now, it's more like an
organic reach always changes,
but now it basically 10X or 20X
the views we were getting because of
starting in the feed with that content.
So I think that for a
lot of business owners,
a lot of smart social media influencers
and online marketers of
all kind, Instagram is just
the platform when you're doing stories,
you have profile posts,
you can do highlights, you can
link back to your business,
have that link in your profile.
If you have a physical address,
have that in your profile.
Churches, you can have your service times,
ways to get to know you.
Instagram stories of photography
to show behind the scenes
of whatever you're doing,
live video on Instagram
and then Instagram TV of snippets,
of whatever the core value
proposition of your business
or your nonprofit is.
It's just a major platform
that people have to be paying attention to
and it's a trend that's
not going away in 2020.
- Yeah, and the fourth trend is something
that I'm really excited about.
We've been experimenting
with over at Think Media
a lot with this platform.
Go ahead and tell us more
about LinkedIn right now, Sean.
- Yeah. So one of the trends we're seeing
that's unfortunate in 2020
and then we actually probably just as a
kind of a mentioned negative trend
is organic reach is going down everywhere.
It just is.
And there's more people coming online.
It's the way that, what
we're seeing on Facebook,
we've been seeing it.
Instagram is tough too.
I mean, so, but hey,
what are you gonna do?
Cry about it?
I mean, you gotta still use it.
And if at one time you
reach 50% of your audience,
now you only reached 5%.
Well, thank God for the
5% that you are reaching,
like keep working it and keep trying
to level up your content.
But one of the one
places that organic reach
is going up is LinkedIn.
And it was almost a little
over a year now ago,
maybe almost two years,
probably about a year and a half
that I went to the first
LinkedIn video creator session at VidCon,
which is historically
a YouTube conference.
They just celebrated 10 years.
It's a conference in Anaheim, California
about 30,000, besides
about a thousand or two
business executives and
corporate executives
is about 28,000 fans of YouTubers.
It's a lot of like 16-year-old girls
and a lot of gamers
and that kind of crowd.
But a few, and then you'd
have the industry track.
And on the industry track, they are
the first ever LinkedIn
video creators session.
And I remember I heard
about that and I was like,
poof, what a joke.
Like, are you kidding me?
Like that place you put your resume,
like video grid or it's like,
what are we talking about?
And I remember though,
I was in the hallway
and I was talking to somebody about that,
I was like, "Did you see that
LinkedIn video creators thing,
like what, hilarious?"
And he was like, "No," somebody I trust.
He's like, "Nah, man.
It's like legit."
You need to see what's
happening over there.
So I went to the session and I met some
of the pioneers of LinkedIn video
that were just posting videos
and had built 30,000, 60,000,
100,000-person communities,
whose videos were getting
5,000 views, 15,000 views.
And they were using it to
boost their current careers.
They were using it to scale consulting
and biz dev opportunities.
They were using it in
so many creative ways.
And here's the big shift,
that LinkedIn had shifted
under a lot of people's watch,
not even aware that it was happening,
from being just a resume posting platform
to a content platform that
is more like a Facebook
or an Instagram to where
you now have a feed
and you kind of always did 'cause
you could do articles,
and texts, and photos,
but now you have kind
of a full-media suite
where videos can show up in your feed.
LinkedIn is releasing live video
and many people have it in beta.
2020, it will certainly
go public to everybody
or there'll be some sort of a
process to get access to it.
And so, LinkedIn's organic reach is crazy
where if you haven't been taking
it, and that was the thing,
despite everything we've
been doing on YouTube
and despite all the energy
I put in in other places,
I started at LinkedIn basically
from scratch like anybody else.
You got like 30 connections.
You know what I mean?
Like you set up your profile once
and then when you were in between jobs
and then you forgot
about it for four years.
I went back, of course, I put the work in,
I started to dive in, study.
That's why we focus so much
at the last couple of growth
video lives on LinkedIn
along with these other platforms.
Because our conference is all
about all of the platforms.
You gotta be diversified in
case an algorithm shifts.
And so, get your profile optimized.
We had a guest speaker,
and even this year,
I'm excited that people
talk about LinkedIn.
That was like gets your profile optimized,
position yourself right.
Dial in these nuances,
here's your content.
Oh, don't do two videos in
a row, but mix up the posts
and here's how the algorithm works.
Learning the best practices,
that's so important.
Now, I mean, I don't even know what it is.
I'm probably coming up on
a little over 10,000, or 12,000, or 13,000
connections plus followers.
It's two different groups
of people on LinkedIn
because we've been putting in the work,
like posting video content,
repurposing a lot of content
because we already have content.
Point is, organic reach there is crazy.
I have spent no money on ads,
have only invested sweat equity,
time equity and have
seen our business grow,
whether that's people discovering
our products and services
or discovering our events.
And so, the opportunity
to invest in LinkedIn,
to build your brand, build your influence,
meet your target audience, meet people
that should be doing business with you
or should be a part of your company
or your business is huge.
And so, in 2020 and beyond,
you gotta be leaning in
to LinkedIn right now,
especially where your
efforts on other platforms
might not producing the
results they once did.
- Yeah. So, that leads into
video trend number five.
What are you seeing for 2020?
- Yeah. And that's
basically sums it all up.
That organic reach is going down,
meaning trend number five is pay to play.
And this is kind of been true.
It was especially two
years ago on Facebook.
At some point, they said Facebook
is now a pay to play platform.
What does that mean?
It means that, wow, for a while there,
like almost a decade ago now,
on Facebook, it was like,
wow, if I've got 1,000 likes
and I post a photo,
850 people will see it.
Like, those days are long gone, right?
- Yeah. (laughs)
- It wasn't pay to play.
It was like, wow, I can grow my business,
grow as an author, grow as
a speaker, grow my ministry.
I could just grow by taking
action on these platforms.
But then it shifted to where it was like
basically we want you to boost posts,
we want you to do light campaigns,
we want you to do Facebook ads.
And that has been true there.
What I'm seeing and what we're seeing
across all platforms now is that
as organic reach is going down,
those that understand paid execution
and paid advertising are gonna
be ones that had an edge.
It makes sense.
And we could complain about this,
you could get mad about it,
but all of these companies,
they've been growing their companies,
Facebook, Instagram, LinkedIn,
it's gonna happen everywhere.
And so, they've been
growing their companies,
they gotta make money somehow
and they make money through advertising.
And as the feed, there's
only that one feed.
Like, it can only fit so much content.
And so, as more people
get on the platform,
as more people post, as
more people are listening
to the Think Marketing
Show, you know what I mean?
Like, in a way, we're constantly like,
we shouldn't be giving
this information away
because it's like that just
more people posting in the feed.
But what our passion is, is like, again,
these are the things that are working now
and we wanna give away
those best practices.
So even this one is then saying, okay,
set your business up in such a way
that you can profit from advertising,
meaning you're selling something online.
Then in that way, you're gonna
get brand lift, brand reach,
brand awareness because if
you're paying for more reach,
and what I'm not saying is that
you just start dumping ads
into trying to get one post
to be seen by more people.
But I am saying that, for example,
when we do YouTube advertising
or Facebook advertising,
it leads directly to
the sale of something,
but in the process of getting there,
we meet thousands of people.
- Right.
- And it's profitable in that process.
Those who learn how to master that process
are the ones that are gonna
win in this new decade.
Understanding and
mastering paid advertising
mixed with organic advertising
and social media marketing,
that's what the Think
Marketing Show is all about.
And, of course, we're
gonna be diving deeper
into those concepts in future episodes.
- Thanks for checking out this episode.
We hope you got a ton of value.
And if you haven't already, subscribe here
to the Think Marketing Show,
wherever you're watching or listening,
- And hey, it would mean the world to us
if you would rate and review
this show on Apple podcast.
- As we grow this movement
of purpose driven content creators,
we encourage you to
share it with a friend,
and we'll see you in the next episode.
(gentle intense music)